this is ajit he's dw's climate reporter
hi edgett hi and this is you in the
1990s
i was a pretty cute baby
that's when the world really started
talking about climate change and when
you were just a child
and this is what it will look like in
2050 hopefully by then we will have
solve global warming i mean if i look
like that when i'm 57 i think i can
handle it well if you like it that much
let's send it to 2050 right now let's
start with a really bold assumption that
we've reached carbon neutrality in 2050
that's what many countries are aiming
for after all what's that like the 2050s
are completely different to the 2020s
let's say that we're on track for
meeting our climate goals and we're
limiting global warming to 1.5 degrees
celsius that's in line with the targets
that world leaders signed up to under
the paris agreement but that means the
planet's one and a half degrees hotter
than it was before the industrial
revolution
and we have to live with the
consequences and there are some things
we won't be able to predict can we
actually remove these wrinkles okay okay
but you are staying in 2050.
okay so let's say this is 2050 we've
limited global warming to 1.5 degrees
celsius
we actually did it
but we suffered some losses along the
way
this for example
what you're seeing here coral reefs
they basically belong in the history
books
the vast majority are all gone even 1.5
degrees was too much for them
and this arctic sea ice well only in the
winter
this victory is actually pretty hollow
on top of that some populated regions
are almost impossible to live in now
experts have been studying these
scenarios for decades and they've always
had lots of predictions
projections indicate that
places around the gulf region
where high humidity and the extreme
temperatures combined
um are becoming difficult uh southeast
asia is becoming difficult um which
includes some of chinese territory
india has difficult areas the amazon
uh
will have problems for humans to to live
in
okay wait ajit you kind of need to ease
me into bad news like that
this doesn't sound like a great victory
at all actually it sounds quite awful
well there is some good news i mean the
air that i'm breathing now is way
cleaner than the air that i grew up
breathing it it feels great
going toward net zero
emissions would also mean that air
pollution will be eliminated
by and large because most of it comes
from the either from indoor
burning of unsustainable fuel wood or
because of the regional use of the
fossil fuels
especially in the urban areas now that
is estimated to cause to eight to nine
million premature deaths mostly in the
developing parts of the world so that
would be a huge healthcare benefit and
another good thing life in 2050 has
become way easier for vegetarians like
me
hang on this sounds like a hard sell my
parents eat lots of meat and they're not
about to stop
the thing is there isn't enough land on
earth for people to have really had that
much of a choice
people had to find ways to eat and farm
more sustainably
we
will probably also have changed our
diets but we will have changed it in
directions where we are eating healthier
and we have a much wider variety of
choices the essence of this is that we
are likely to eat less meat or at least
less red meat
but in general we will eat more
plant-based food and
we will
eat more healthily and we will probably
get used to already in our childhood
to the taste of different mouth-watering
alternative
meat alternatives and there's something
else i love about this emissions-free
world lots and lots of trees
we planted them to help suck co2 out of
the atmosphere but it's not as simple as
just planting forests right
won't the changing climate affect
wildlife
even in in our middle attitudes we see
heat stress in the forests due to
combination of drought and heat and and
this is a sign that some of our native
species may no longer do very well in
the climate of the future
so this is a challenge
for people to plan
we have not only the climate crisis but
in parallel we have the biodiversity
crisis and the two of them are
intertwined
sounds awful but a lot of trees at least
help us suck more co2 out of the
atmosphere than we are producing right
yes but
the problem is we've already heated the
planet by 1.5 degrees celsius and that
means heat waves and wildfires have
become more common and stronger
and every tree that's burned down is co2
that we're putting back into the
atmosphere
now heat waves have always been deadlier
for poorer people and for older people
but that trend has just gotten worse
and i guess air conditioning is not an
option
well a lot of people still need to use
it but it also takes up a huge amount of
electricity
and so depending on what your job is it
might be easier if you could actually
just stay indoors most houses old or new
have had to find ways to protect
themselves from the heat
they've had to become energy positive
which means that they're producing more
energy than they consume
energy positive buildings are much more
comfortable both thermally and also air
quality wise we will always feel that
there is this nice fresh air
inside we won't feel cold or warm um in
general also
the illumination the lighting situation
will be much more comfortable uh
basically based on on what we want okay
but if you have to leave your house
during a heat wave can't you just cool
off by jumping into a local pool it's
not that simple here in northern europe
we have water shortages in the summer
it's a problem everywhere even though
we've limited warming to 1.5 degrees
it's still wrecked the natural water
storage system
glaciers used to hold fresh water as ice
in the winter releasing it in the summer
but they're mostly gone the previously
stored water is now raising the sea
level making many places unlivable
and floods as a result are also becoming
stronger places that relied on glaciers
melting in the summer for their water
supply are now facing shortages that
have affected drinking water in
agriculture i think glaciers that are
disappearing in
essentially everywhere in the world um
do pose a big danger because they're
source of much of the river runoff
so as they melt the runoff will decrease
think of the you know indian
subcontinent the freshwater uh challenge
will be even bigger than it is today in
such a world if we don't act immediately
and apply globally mitigation and
adaptation measures okay wow the world
out there sounds pretty grim in 2050.
what about you edgit are you still a
climate reporter do we even still need
climbed reporters once we go carbon
neutral oh i've still got plenty to do
there are so many extreme weather events
that have been made stronger or more
likely because of climate change
it can be pretty busy
[Music]
we are
projecting that there will be more
impacts
even under 1.5 degrees global warming
and
staying at 1.5 is beneficial compared to
two so every bit of warming matters very
very clearly
so yes in terms of living conditions um
the environment
may be more hostile
depending on the place where where you
are
and you cannot generalize this for all
places but on on average um in the
places especially where unfortunately
human societies are already very
vulnerable
these um changes will be will be largest
yeah that's something that hasn't
changed the poorest people are the
hardest hit
some regions have become almost
impossible to survive in while some
islands have been literally swept under
the sea because sea levels have risen so
high poor the poorest of the poor let's
say they wouldn't be able to
to to afford to migrate so they because
there's a term to call the subgroup of
population is the trapped population the
immobile population so they may wish to
move but they cannot
and that's uh that's also worrying
because that if people need to to use
migration as an adaptation strategy and
they cannot
and the rich of course they would not
probably yes unlikely that they need to
migrate because they can cope with the
consequences much better so it's a
middle income that have certain
resources to allow them to migrate and
to be more likely to move due to
changing climatic conditions
to cover these topics you would need to
fly all around the world well to be
honest that's one thing that's been very
slow to change carbon free flights are
really only starting to get off the
ground now in 2050. we know how to
travel without greenhouse gas emissions
with
trains
they are electric mostly we know how to
do that with
cars if we for example go for electric
cars or electric buses
there we have the technology already how
to do this
we can also travel by ship short
distances there's also electric ships or
or barges
but where it's difficult today with
technology is
large ships and long ship travel and air
travel we need to find innovative
solutions how to still be able to uh go
with a ship or with a plane from a to b
um and i'm hopeful that we are
innovative because i think humans want
to travel okay so this is what a future
will look like if
we keep warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
but we're not on track to do that right
like despite some countries claiming
they want to be carbon neutral by 2050
not at all politicians pledges to
actually meet these climate goals are
not nearly enough and their policies to
actually achieve that are even worse the
good news i guess is that we can stop it
if people take the right decisions i
think some of the things that we
experience today and that will intensify
both in severity and frequency are the
storms the floods dry spells uh this is
a big danger for many many people um and
this can be at the same time let me also
say that even these things that we
cannot stop
they'll be significantly lower in one
and a half world one and a half degree
world then they would be in two or three
degree worlds and that's the direction
in which we are heading uh so these are
really huge challenges but if i may let
me also observe that um
the stabilization at one and a half
degrees is still possible so i guess
that's the good news well that's enough
2050 for me then that's enough for me
too honestly there are enough climate
problems to worry about in the present
before i even start thinking about the
future
hey this is dustin i'm one of the
reporters who worked on this video
we tried something new with this and we
would love to have your feedback on it
so if you want to please leave us a
comment a like or even a dislike down
below